all right y'all you know how we do it so
let's do
it ladies and
gentlemen welcome
back to your favorite
podcast
W
yeah real
g g
[Music]
yeah what's up y'all welcome back to
riin with Griffin you know how we do
it oh back again with the podcast
talking into the wrong mic um let's
see let's get caught up on the
NFL let's get caught up on what's going
on with the SAG strike what's going on
in my world what's going on I saw I love
that show billions is finally the season
finale and want to talk about that and
you know news and notes from around the
world and as always welcome
[Music]
back
yeah welcome back to Griffin with
Griffin y'all uh thanks for being here
as oh you know what I have it on the
wrong screen I supposed to have it on
this screen oh
well gin ER gin woo woo woo I got a new
chair I'll talk about that in a second
but
um uh you know thanks for subscribing so
make sure you hit the Subscribe button
so you can get you know so you can get
your uh notifications that the the thing
is on make sure you hit me on the twitch
cuz I twitch every single day so you
know come check me out there that'll be
fun time
and then I you know and then I'm on
patreon that's just to support the show
honestly you know but you can support it
in all kinds of ways you could be a
YouTube member you could be a twitch
follower a twitch subscriber or you
could be you know a patreon member so
all that stuff helps support the show
so you know so I appreciate that wait
let me get uh oh man I like to get
everything ready before I start uh I got
this new chair I I have to put it
together and sh out to ewin racing but
my old chair busted my fat ass broke it
this way so I have one of my like
podcast chairs but it's weird so like
you know my you know I gota I actually
got to sit back like this to like really
make it like you can see me good but
when I'm on the keyboard I got to come
up here and do all this stuff so you
know it you know it it is what it is um
so yes so I got I got to put that chair
together that's the only thing it comes
you know it doesn't
come ready to go which [__] you I
hate that sometimes sometimes that's why
you get like the conier service for
things because you don't want to like
put things
together uh so it's you know it's
tough
um
anyways so anyways we're here riffin
with Griffin thanks a lot uh for being a
part of the show I got some I got my Q&A
up I got some um what do you call
it uh whatever this is oh the C question
answer and I got a poll up about the NFL
so you guys can check that out so today
was my first day of my personal training
so I went to there's a place down the
street from where I live it's like a
15minute walk and that's why I picked it
because I could just walk there which is
part of the whole workout process get
myself going when I get there uh this
old black dude is my my trainer cool
dude you know he's almost 60 and he's
like in like the best shape you've ever
want to see anybody be in that's that
and you know and I'm like well if he
could do it I could do it right so you
know I'm starting my workout Journey so
and there we go
um yeah so it was tough the first day
was tough man you know so he kind of
like went around the rounds just to see
what I could do you know it's like all
right so we did some mat work with the
you know what what were we doing like
different sort of like things like how
many push-ups can I do different types
of like uh back exercises and then I was
doing like I did some lifting you know I
was on one of those machines doing the
you know 12 reps of this with like
minimal weight and then like doing some
curls and then doing some some shoulder
work so he kind of put me through the
rounds but then when I finish I'm
walking home I'm feeling good you know I
feel real good right now and you know
the thing is I what I realize is you
know sometimes you work out and then you
stop working out because you may not be
getting the result that you want want
because I think all of us want to look
good naked I mean I think that's what it
is you know we want to look good naked
[Music]
um and it's like so when we don't
achieve that goal right away you think
that this is all like what am I doing
this for because you're not seeing the
results you want but when you get to my
age I realize now it like the main thing
is just feel good feel good feel healthy
you know clearheaded uh you know good
heart health and so just doing like a
regular ass workout just to feel that
you're winning you know so then like if
you wanted to do like well I want to
have a six-pack abs that's a whole other
mindset that you want to that you want
to get to you know and so yeah right now
the way I feel right now I'm was like oh
this is why I I'm telling myself this is
why I have to do this I have to do this
just so I feel good like there's
something about it that you just you
feel good man no matter how hard it is
and you're going through that process
and what is it like really ultimately
for the average person you know 20
minutes 30 minutes could be great you
know just whatever workout you're
walking you're on a treadmill you're on
a just for the walk not for like you
know and just so when you finish your
heart is like pumping and you adrenaline
is going you're like oh wow I actually I
feel good I mean that should be enough
you know that should be enough for you
to like oh let me continue this for that
and then if it's like the goal is well I
want to be in better shape I want to
look good naked I want to do then if you
can't achieve that at least you could go
down to well I'm just doing this well I
have to continue to do this because I
want to feel good so I prepaid for 24 uh
sessions with the guy um just to like
because when you prepaid it just Challen
you like you think about that money like
oh I can't lose that money it was
expensive so you know um we'll see how
it goes we will see how it goes looking
good feeling good and uh we'll we'll
we'll figure that out so that was one of
the things that I did um oh in terms of
my poll you know what I totally forgot
to put the Eagles on
there the Eagles should have been one of
my teams on my poll guys so I know the
Eagles is the where where is you know
but maybe that's me trolling too so I
didn't do that on purpose but I just
completely forgot about them because I
was doing this quick because I was
behind right now so anyways thanks for
that um car update love my car man I do
Lucid shout out to Lucid Motors um I
just I love driving my car I just got an
overthe A update I love that stuff
because then you get in your car and
you're like oo what's new CU they had
some issues like all if I had to tell
you some issues they had with my the the
native navigation
system you couldn't save you could save
work and you could save home that's it I
was like what so so I got on the horn
with the people like yo you telling me
that you can only save your work and
home address on the navigation that
don't even make no sense you should have
favorites this is my restaurant I for me
it would be like The Comedy Store the
Laugh Factory all these different places
I like you know so and then the over to
a update just came was was that so
there's still some things um it has
Alexa in it you know and what I'm find
what I what's strange is the Alexa in
the car is not necessarily connected to
to the system in the car so for instance
if I'm in the car and I say Alexa drive
home it's going to say what's your home
address and I'm like well my home
address is in the system so what I
realized I needed to go to like the
Alexa app right and then I found the car
and I was like oh my car is on my Alexa
app now you know because it's part of
connected to my account and I'm looking
at oh you put your favors so then you
you connect everything on Alexa and then
when you're in the car it's Alexa but
it's not connected to the car which I
find strange even like for instance you
know Alexa is Amazon so I listen to a
lot of audiobooks so you I looked at the
thing and it said it said what what do
you want things you could do with Alexa
and one of the thing was continue
audible book and I was like oh that's
cool so I went Alexa continue audible
book and Alexa started playing my book
from where I left off and I was like oh
this is great but the thing is it's not
connected to my phone and it's not you
know and then audible is isn't one of
the apps that's on the car so it's
literally just Alexa doing it so I don't
know if that's good or bad uh but that's
one of two of the
things um one of the other things is
like I like not having to have a key so
like you just walk to the car you walk
to the car just Lucid air touring right
so you walk to the car and then the car
just opens lights come on and whatever
is going on and then you get in the car
you got your phone you know and then it
like has this like face recognition so
it like recognizes you and it's like all
right cool but it also recognizes my
phone but here's the thing like when you
go to
valet you got to have your key fob or
they have this like credit card type key
but then the credit card type key you
have to have a code so they have a thing
called a guest I didn't realize this but
they have a guest code but then you got
to give the valet guy you go like okay
here it is and the code is this that's
how you start the car that's kind of a
hassle so it's like I guess if you're
going to go someplace that you know
you're going to valet you should bring
your key fob
but other than that I do to me there
should be a valet mode you know what I'm
saying there should be like you when
you're getting out your car you go this
this is valet mode until I get back into
the car till I turn valet mode off or
something you know so actually you just
reminded myself I have to send I have to
send that to uh
um you know I have to send that to them
um and oh oh somebody some just ask me
right now about the range what kind of
range am I getting okay so this is
another thing so it says you're supposed
to get 400 miles right but it's very
clear to the when I'm talking to the
engineer that he wasn't the engineer but
he was like an engineer I forgot what
the guy's T what he he has done but
anyway all the people that that I've
been talking to it's very clear that the
range of the car is going to get better
you know because the car has to figure
out like what's your driving habits and
patterns your Char like where are you
charging how are you charging and then
you'll get the range like so if I go to
my car right now if I go to the car app
right now let's see um so right now my
full charge is
374 miles right now so that's far from
what they said it was going to be but
they're saying that that's going to get
better you know as the car you know cuz
I only have like I don't even have a
th000 miles on the car yet you know so I
don't know we'll see I'll keep you guys
posted I love all the techy stuff um so
we'll see
where where that's going you know what I
mean so we'll fig we'll figure it out
but anyways all right let's go
to
comments okay comments uh first up so I
had this little video of this joke I was
doing about The Little Mermaid a joke
I've been doing since the thing came out
you know I'm all right so I got this guy
that says Theo Von wants his bitb so
first I want to say [__] you to that guy
for just even implying that like you
know it parallel thinking is a thing and
trust me bro I don't I've never taken a
joke in my entire life you know uh and
those kind of jokes I've been doing
jokes about movies for years so this is
what I do you can go look at my Comedy
Central half hour I was talking about
the movie Insidious so my joke is my
joke and so
yeah so you know what I mean and when
you talk about one of my friends you
acting like you trying to start some
[__] it ain't gonna happen don't worry
you're not that important but I just
wanted to talk about this because I
can't stand that [__] when these uh
[__] come to be like oh man you
doing somebody's joke never ever ever
anyways uh Izzy v62 this episode is good
thank
you I like what I love those Hey listen
sometimes you need those kind of
positive comments in your life people
just say like hey this was good so I
like it um let's see Stephen Rogers 943
great job Eric just wanted to say I've
watched over 200 episodes of riffin over
the year appreciate your personality and
perspective well that's great it's good
to know that people are actually
watching and listening to the show love
that uh let's
see uh okay Bobby Jones 7441 I always
thought The Stereotype was that men
don't look at the instructions when
assembling something sounds like you're
the woman in the scenario
Eric no it's like we let me tell you
something let me take a moment to praise
my beautiful wife you know what she is
she does
research that's her thing like if she's
going to buy something like a crib or
like we're doing baby stuff right she's
going to buy a crib or she's going to
buy a whatever for the baby trust me she
gonna be in her on her computer for an
hour like looking up things looking at
comments looking at like ratings and
then she's like okay I found this is the
best one we should get so when we're
putting together together this we're
putting wallpaper on the wall she's on
Tik Tok like best way to put up
wallpaper so she sent me like three
videos of like people putting up
wallpaper you know what I mean and so
she was like did you look at the videos
did you look at the videos and I'm like
I I skimmed over them I'm like oh okay
because it was you know Tik Tok videos
they're like a minute they're not even
like a minute some of them are just like
like here's a tip for putting up
wallpaper you know so I looked at it you
know and and we got this sticker it's a
sticker it's a sticker you know I got to
show you guys the picture
you know what I mean I gotta just I got
to just show you guys the the the the
picture of the wallpaper you know so
anyway but it's like it's it's just
that's why that person said that because
it was just so
funny
uh anyways
um somebody is is ishma do Domingo 2249
shout out to you man the intro music is
super Doper Fuego yeah that's uh you
know dopa pod shout out to those guys
great funk band it's just I love they
are the best and they made this intro
song for me and I'm still using it that
now the joke is where's Wiggy Marty
Marty the zebra said where's
Wiggy Wiggy's around all right go look
go go go go ask go to Wiggy's Instagram
and be like where are you man why aren't
you on uh
whatever you know and then here's oh
here's a this is we'll call this the
hater comment of the week from James Soo
259 Lucid air lame AF
okay okay all right bro I'm sure your
Honda Civic is
dope uh let's see then theop f82 she's
like ultimate wife material there's
something talk about some a video of
Rachel and I um oh somebody said oh and
speaking of I'm glad somebody put this
out uh it said I'm excited to see you at
Sid Splitters yes I am going to be at
Sid Splitters this weekend unfortunately
you know sadly my Orlando date was
cancelled you know and just full
transparency is just like I'm not a sell
tickets two weeks ahead of time guy
three weeks ahead of time guy a lot of
times people come buy my ticket last
minute day before day of and that club
is like not into that so I had like 20
something tickets sold and that just
wasn't enough for them and then
Chappelle just dropped a theater a
theater show in Orlando on the same
night so but I got a message from
somebody that was like yo man I I chose
you over Chapel I was like yeah but I
needed like a thou I needed like 500
people to do that so it just worked out
like that but I I still think they
should have had the show I'm actually
I'm actually disappointed that that that
it happened like that you know without
even trying to give a chance but you
know there are people and like the club
itself like where the [__] your
promotions you know like you know what I
mean like they like these clubs like
that's your city I don't live in Orlando
I'm not from Orlando I'm from California
so you're telling me that you don't have
a reputation in your neighborhood you
don't have a reputation in your
community that you could be like hey
come watch this good show we're hey this
is going to be a good show and you go as
a club you go hey come to my club you
guys should come to the CL cuz this
guy's funny no they don't do that they
just rely on you like so that's why it's
only like YouTubers and and you know
people like that that can like you know
really sell out way ahead of time
because that's what it is I mean
everybody that comes to my show is like
damn you're really funny they're always
like wow more people should be here
you're so funny listen I'm hilarious man
I when you I really love doing stand-up
comedy and I put on a fantastic show
trust me you're going to have a good
time if you come to my show all right
Love Me Or Hate Me You're GNA have a
good time at my show um so anyways so
now I'm looking for someplace else in
Orlando you know I got to find a
different spot in Orlando because I want
to do I want to go I think the Orlando
people they're they're there they want
to see comedy and I you know it's just
like I just want to have a partnership
with the the the place to be like yeah
we want you we want you here let's let's
let's let's pump this up so anyways it
is what it is once again thanks for the
comments guys uh every week you know
love the comments you'll make it on the
show
so um anyways anyways where am I what
are we talking about what are we doing
um oh yeah let's go to you know what
let's go to uh some of my riffin topics
uh some stuff that I want to talk about
you know I have talked about this for a
while now oh whoops what happened to my
uh let me see Instagram post here we go
boom so this one's a big one here not a
big one but this is just like I've been
talking about this so Twitter now X
admits Elon Musk has destroyed more than
half its
value um it's
like first of all I don't even know how
the business of this
works um but I've said in the past and
I'll say again this was the dumbest
purchase in history
there isn't a dumber purchase than this
cuz it was so
expensive like I don't I still don't
understand it I know that he didn't
write a $44 billion check and I know a
lot of people think that they think he
wrote a $44 billion check no this is
just an evaluation of the company like
he gave stock options in Tesla I
believe some cash of his own like 11 13
billion which is is still a lot right um
and and then for some reason the
evaluation of the company uh is part of
the value of the I don't know how it all
works right but it just sounds like a
lot of money for what and so like again
maybe this is going to work itself out
in a couple years and he's going to be
like aha look what I did but as of right
now to me he has destroyed the
confidence and and by the way probably
confidence that we should probably
confidence that we shouldn't have had in
this company in the first place like who
was in charge of Twitter before we
didn't know we didn't really know maybe
some of you knew because you were like
in the know but most of you you just go
on Twitter you go and then you hear
about stuff like oh Twitter is uh uh you
know uh against like you know violence
again whatever their like terms of
service and the things they were doing
you were just kind of like okay but if
you think about it there was there had
to be a person behind that a Comm ite
someone someone was making a call that
hey we have to filter these things out
we didn't know who it was and we kind of
just said Twitter what Elon did was he
made it him he made it him so like him
or hate him it becomes like you feel
like the buck stops with him and we
don't like it after a while we're like
well hold on a second like like this is
you I don't know if I agree with just
you I don't know if uh you know but he's
trying his best man you know this this
it's tough they can't all be winners you
know PayPal SpaceX Tesla Twitter I mean
the guy's gonna have a couple of Duds so
we'll see where it goes from here some
of the other things he's you know he's
doing things he's trying to put internet
in the Middle East area that you know
the the people aren't receiving Internet
in those places I don't know what the
holdup is just do it you know but
there's like a fight about that I mean I
don't know the guy's involved in a lot
of stuff but this is one of those ones
where I was like I don't know Elon
you you might have made a mistake with
this
one but I agree with you somebody in the
chat leftovers richest guy in the world
he's not stressing yeah but that's the
Reon okay you know what let's address
that but that doesn't mean you could
just go nah you know what I'm saying
like this is a thing that affects
hundreds of millions of people like this
is a product we all use people use for
information people use for you for
comedy for some people get their news
from this some people you know it can't
just be oh well he's Rich so it don't
matter if he does it right like that's
what's wrong in the first place that's
how people feel about it it's like oh
it's just a rich guy that need that he
had the money to buy it so he did like
the NFL don't let you do that you know
think about this in the NFL you can't
just be rich and be like I want an NFL
team no no no they like they're like
that that boy Club is like well are you
about football there's like an extensive
there's interviews it's not just money
and then if you in there messing up they
kick you out they're like nah you got to
go you messing up our whole product I
mean people should be like that you know
what I mean like just cuz he's Rich it
don't mean he can just buy something and
then when it [__] up he
goes I still got 300 billion in the bank
and if you support that like damn what
does that say about you not necessarily
this guy that just said that in the chat
because I get that it's just like a hey
it was just a offhanded comment that
he's probably not struggling I get you
I'm not attacking that guy in chat I'm
just saying there are people that you
shouldn't feel like that is what I'm
saying that's my perspective but anyways
y'all know y'all know how it is next one
oh I love this story man researchers
create a smart toilet
that can identify unique [__]
[__] prints and monitor your
health I've been saying this like I
wanted to go on Shark Tank with a with a
with a [__] camera this is my idea I
think I even said this on the podcast
one time this is what you want you
want this is what the the the smart
toilet should be telling you this keep
wiping
right two more wipes buddy because
you got a little bit going on here you
know I think the toilet should talk to
you ooh [__] looking destroyed today
everything okay I mean that's where the
AI should go I want a AI toilet I want a
AI toilet like I have a toothbrush that
lets you know that you're brushing your
teeth too hard and then you ease up it
has like lights on it and then there's
an app is there's an app that like it'll
show you where you've brushed your teeth
in your mouth and you can like go around
and be like oh I didn't get this side I
yeah I want the toilet to do that you
know like let you know you know you need
to know that that but hole is
pristine
anyways so thank you scientists for like
you know stealing my idea you know what
I mean oh and then there's this one last
one is this one and this is like a bit I
have but a Georgia restaurant adds a $50
sear charge to loud Families bill for
adults unable to parent listen I'm about
to be a parent and you know you might
catch me in a restaurant with a
three-year-old running around being like
ah Griffin I told you but I'mma do my
best to like
hey let's not do this here when you get
home you can run around but when we in
public no that's just something I'm
going to push for it might be a pipe
dream but but if a if if my kid is in a
restaurant acting up and then the
restaurant's like well you know you got
to pay $50 for that guess what I'm
paying the $50 and I'm also apologizing
because yeah you at a restaurant and
then like these kids are just running
around like they crazy and the parents
are just sitting there like
oh I'm just saying get your parent on
you know who knows in a year two years
from now I might be on here being like
guys I was completely
wrong but for
now
you know I totally agree with this you
know parents get your [__]
together
anyways
um all right guys so let's get into
football let's get in let's get into
football wait do I still have a football
I think I still have my football I do
you know what let's change the
background to my football background you
know why doesn't this go automatically I
don't understand this dude I got to go
to that real quick and then you come
back to this and here it is all right so
like I say when I look at my
poll if I look at the poll right now we
got people say that Chiefs 27% Dolphins
28% Raven 6% and then where is question
mark so that's probably the
Eagles yeah I think the Eagles are the
best team in the league right now I
think as of uh you know what's happened
if you look at the records right now the
Eagles are the only team the the Eagles
are the only team that only have one
loss they're seven and one right now and
they've had really good games they've
had bad games but they find ways to win
they're real complete team they got a
great secondary which they just they
just they just got somebody new I forgot
the guy's name but they got a good o
line a good D line they got a smart
quarterback that can run and throw they
can win in multiple ways they can rush
for 250 yards or they can throw four
touchdowns and have and they got one of
the best receivers in the league right
now that dude which one is it is it uh
Devonte Adams not Devonte Adams what am
I saying you guys what's the Eagles
receiver put it in the chat but the one
Eagles receiver the dudes had like five
games in a row with over a hundred yards
and a touchdown or something it's like
the dude's like uh the dude's balling
right now so um Eagles are the number
one team
um so love that so um you know if you
just let's start in the NFC right what's
been going on right now Cowboys love
them or hate them they're 5-2 I don't
think they could beat good teams and I
think when it's when it's all said and
done they're going to lose in the
playoffs again and it's going we're
going on 30 years since they've even
been to an NFC Championship game so but
we'll see rest of the AFC East is just
trash the Giants what a joke like what a
joke that they paid Daniel Jones $40
million pH we'll see we'll see how that
plays out man but all you Giants fans it
must be tough to be a Giants fan right
now and the commanders Eric benemy you
know he leaves the Kansas City Chiefs
you know championships on the run and
now he goes there and he's just not
doing it you know not everybody's like
under Andy Reid and having Patrick
Mahomes the guy looks great right now
but hopefully he gets gets his seal legs
let's let's hope that he gets one more
you know he stays there then builds up
that he could eventually be a head coach
but I don't know Seahawks man Seahawks
can't hate on the Seahawks they doing
good they're 5-2 they got some solid
wins uh they just I just don't know if
they have enough they got two great
receivers we'll see can goino Smith do
it and is that defense good enough but
I'm not going to be surprised you know
but right now they're at they're a top
to AFC West so check that out um 49ers
three losses in a row Brock p is Brock p
is looking like the last pick in the
draft you know it's a great story that
you know he he that was his first loss
three games ago in the regular season
great story and I think it was more
about the story than anything else but
Brock p is um you know he needs his
players that system I don't know man
it's like it's hard to say he's a Young
quarterback he hasn't even had a full
season of games yet right they're on
that how many games five six seven eight
and then the yeah I think he's just got
to 17 like a full season a full 17 games
so he's a Young quarterback so maybe by
next year he'll be the guy but right now
they they're they're built to win now
but their def here's the thing though
their defense they ain't doing it but
they got that they just traded for that
guy from Washington but that guy's
parentally hurt so we'll see 49ers you
know and then the Rams and Cardinals
garbage Lions you know I like the Lions
I thought they were poed they're going
to win that division especially with
Kirk Cousins going out and the Packers
being garbage the lions are going to
cruise into the the playoffs uh with and
because they're going to dominate the
NFC North but can they beat any good
teams we'll see we'll see uh but they're
but they're six and two but they just
those two the four the six wins not very
good teams really except for the you
know the first game against the Chiefs
but like they didn't have Kelsey or
their best defensive player Jones so I
don't know and then the NFC South it's a
shame that one of those teams is going
to go to the playoffs cuz they're
bat they're just garbanzo beans man the
Falcons the Saints the Bucks and the
Panthers yuck worst div wor worst
division in football man worst division
in football all right let's go over to
the AFC now Dolphins six and2 they got
the same issue as as Detroit to me they
can't beat anybody good because every
time they do Play Somebody good they get
Molly whopped so I don't know we'll see
what's going on with the dolphins bills
another just stupid inconsistent team
like it's like what one day they're like
oh wow they're beating the Dolphins by
30 and then they're losing to the
Patriots right so it's like they're so
inconsistent but we'll see hey I got to
give it to the Jets four and three they
make they doing their thing man they
probably not gonna make the they might
yeah they won't make the playoffs
because of yeah but maybe they can
string together some wins you know it's
looking good for next year if if uh
Aaron Rogers comes back and poor
patriots man uh bill bellich it's time
to retire man or move on time to move on
but he just seems like the old guy
that's like you know it's done Chiefs
six and two they just took a loss you
know they're missing something right
they're a great team and Patrick Mahomes
you always feel like he could do it but
something's missing they need to get a
receiver I don't oh they should have
tried their best to get uh Devonte Adams
right who am I Devonte Adams is the one
in the Raiders right and there's another
Devonte on the the Eagles I'm
confused but anyways Devon thank you
Devonte Smith and AJ Brown thank you and
then Devonte Adams is with the Raiders
he they needed to they should have
traded him they just fired their general
manager and their coach
like one of these when when your team is
you know you have the Davis Family like
the new guy he just he's just a
billionaire that just doesn't know how
to run R A Team like it's like that's
when it start the Raiders is a Big Brand
that's a big football brand the Raiders
and they're never good get it together
man Broncos garbanzo beans now Ravens I
had the Ravens is like one of the best
teams I mean they got a great team they
really do ravens look good and when they
lose you could point to why they lose
they [__] Dro eight P eight catches
to that one game they lost eight they
they dropped eight balls are are you
kidding me they should have won they
they really should be seven and one
right now um and then the rest of that
division is just garbanzo Steelers
Browns
Bengals who knows Bengals though they're
they're lasting the the division right
now but you saw what they did to the
49ers and Joe burrow is just that dude
so I I I I feel like they're gonna in
their next five games they're probably
going to be like four and one or five
and0 cuz they're just they're they're
cooking right now I think by the end of
the season Bengals will be right up
there jaguars another one of those teams
man are they good I don't know they look
good so you got Jaguars Dolphins you
know
Detroit uh even Dallas like what are
bills what are they are they good so but
the AFC South another terrible division
terrible terrible they Jaguars are going
to smoke that division they're going to
they're going to the playoffs and we'll
see what they can do when they get there
you know what I mean so we we'll see
what's going on with that so other than
that though I think uh the football
season has been real good I love
watching it my fantasy team is trash
right now four and four every time and
it's like not even my fault you know
it's like one guy gets hurt the other
guy you know some garbage but we'll see
um we'll see how it goes but so far it's
been pretty good and right now if I had
to pick I think if I had to pick I would
say the Eagles are the best team in the
league I think the Eagles are for
they're the team to be in the NFC and I
think it's up for grabs anywhere else
I'm not going to be surprised if it's
you know like if you see um if it's like
eagles any one of those teams in the in
the NFC Championship Game who knows you
know it could be the Seahawks the 49ers
the Lions you know it could be any one
of those teams can make it and it would
just kind of Be Like H I think it's the
NFC is the Eagles to lose so I see them
going back to the Super Bowl if I had to
pick I would say the Eagles are going
going back to the Super Bowl um so you
know you guys what you you tell me what
you guys think but yeah man that's my uh
football take of the
week so as you guys know U oh wait we
got's change this let us change this
baby NFL talk is
over how come this doesn't I don't
understand why this doesn't switch man
like I see here boom boom let's go here
it doesn't switch unless I do this so
let's go let's go to that then we'll go
back to
this that'll switch it okay so you know
sag is still on strike guys you know the
Riders Union they they got what they
they they got a good deal they'll
probably strike again in three years I
me I think all these are going to strike
again in three years once these deals
are done but sag is still on strike and
I just wanted to go over what I thought
about it you know um so these are the
three there's four major things that sag
is asking for and I don't know if you
guys know about these things but sag
wanted increased wages and benefits so
sag is asking for an 11% wage increase
in the first year of a new contract
followed by 4% increase in the second
and third years so that's
like you know it's weird though because
I don't know how so this is just like
the base salaries it's not for like
stars of a show you know this only kicks
in for like if for the increases so for
instance if you go if if you sign on to
a series and they give you your salary
let's say you're getting $30,000 an
episode you know and that actually like
on a network sitcom is actually low end
but let's say you getting 30,000 an
episode so now they're saying in the
contract you you'll get a 4% increase
per year you know so then that you know
so I don't know and then 11% increase in
the main wages which would mean this is
for like this isn't for the Stars this
is for the regular actors so if the SAG
minimum is like 700 they want an 11%
increase of that so you know I think
that's fair uh the amount of money
that's being put out there that's not
that's one where I go just give us that
I don't get that um thank you the union
is also seeking to increase contribution
to pension and health plans yeah you
know what I mean like our health plan is
it's it's you would think it used to be
really good now it's kind of like what
the [__] Fu with the health plan so we
got to get a better and and and I think
about the health plan now for myself
because you know I'm about to have a kid
and I got to put my wife on my health
plan and it's like y let's get what's
going on with this health plan so that's
something you know um AJ Brown thank you
y'all I messed up on that
again it's AJ Brown and Devonte Smith
and then Devonte Adams thank you um the
big one that there I think that it's
kind of like this thing is like we're
being distracted by this is the AI stuff
I think that's a big distraction and the
money stuff is way more important but
protection against generated AI uh sag
after is concerned about the growing use
of of AI to create synthetic media which
could be used to replace actors the
union is asking for a definition of
acceptable use of generated AI so yeah
you know I don't know they're going to
have to figure that out I don't think
that
like you know it's like let's say they
wanted to continue Workaholics and they
just like instead of hiring the guys and
everything they bought the rights to the
show then they just made AI versions of
us that would suck you know I just think
that if you're using someone's likeness
and I thought that was a thing anyway
like I don't know why this just doesn't
go under like you can't use my name and
likeness so it should be like a
licensing deal they're like okay well we
want to use you uh but you don't we
don't need to show up but here's here's
the amount of money because we're using
you okay that should be a thing so
hopefully they get that now here's the
one where I don't think we're going to
get this and honestly I don't know if we
should if I'm just being 100 about it um
Fair compensation for streaming
residuals this is the big one guys sag
after believes that actors are not being
fairly compensated for their work on
streaming platforms the union is asking
for check this out a 2% share of the
revenue that each show generates for a
streaming platform to be paid to
performers that's so nuanced because
one now Hulu they got no business not
paying uh for advertis because they
they've been showing commercials since
day one Hulu bin had commercials on
there so that one you can now know the
amount of revenue generated because
here's a show
let's say a Show's going to be on Hulu
and then Hulu says to the advertisers
here's the numbers this many people
watch this show and this is how much you
have to pay to to advertise so if that's
the case then they can have an algorithm
to be like all right this show is
generating this amount of money and add
Revenue now how you determine how how
much a
show should get of the of the
subscription rate Revenue that is
something that I don't understand how
they're going to figure that out you
know if I pay $10 a month you know and
it's like and and and here's one of the
shows I watch is a really popular show
am I watching you know like how much of
my $10 a month should go towards that 2%
to go you know what I mean it's that
that's going to be the thing where to me
it's going to be hard to figure out so
you know
2%
of the share of each show G that's a
astronomical amount of money
considering what it is you know so I
don't know how they're going to do that
they'll figure it out I mean it should
be figured out there should be a way to
figure it out but you know you're
talking about like these streaming
services are like you know they're like
hey this is I think I've used this
analogy on here but I'll just do it
again whatever it could be your first
time watching the show but it's like a
museum man like you know it's like a
museum Commission painters let's say a
muse Museum pays an artist and they go
here's this amount of money and we'll
keep your F we're going to keep your
we're going to keep your art in our
museum for five years and here's the
amount of money we're going to pay you
to do that and you're like okay cool
then the museum starts to go why are we
doing that let's just buy art so then
the museum goes to the same artist and
goes hey can can we buy your art we want
to buy it okay here's your art we're
gonna pay you this amount of money to
buy the art thank you we have the
receipt it's ours now we we told you
what we wanted you to paint you paint it
and then we bought it we paid you to do
that now it's ours and then we're going
to put this painting in our Museum and
the Muse it's hanging up in the museum
then they buy they go to like they go to
like a thousand artists and go yeah we
want to buy all your and then they put
it in their Museum and then they charge
people to go into the museum then the
people are walk and then the artist
comes in the museum and they're looking
around like damn there a lot of people
in here how much was it to get into this
Museum oh wow it's $30 a ticket then
they go back to the the go hey um we
want some of that money you're charging
to watch to look at our art and then
people like I bought it from you this is
why I bought it you know it's a weird
thing and then they're going to be like
so then they're going to be like this
how do you
determine in the museum how you going to
determine of the Thousand paintings that
you bought
who should get the most money is it the
most people watching a particular paint
painting yeah but what if that painting
is at the front door of the museum the
museum is like yeah but we put your
painting people have to look at it it's
the first thing they
see is that the reason why it has the
most views you know and then they put
another painting in the way in the back
of the room which could be really great
and they're getting no love because of
where they are in the location so so now
they getting messed over CU you know
what I'm trying to say guys you know
it's like that's how it is to me for
shows that go on Netflix I just think
it's like how do you determine so they
have to figure out some sort of
algorithm and it can't just be strictly
views because if Netflix is like hey we
spent $100 million on Stranger Things if
we spent like we spent 30 million dollar
an episode to make stranger things you
damn right that's going to be on the
algorithm they going to be like hey uh
you need to watch this show they gonna
be pumping it out is it because it's
good or is it because it's popular like
like they could do that for any show
they could pump up any show they want
hey guys watch this show then we like oh
you know you know you know when some
[__] come up on Netflix you're like oh
what's that should I watch that huh that
looks good but if you never saw it or
never heard about it you wouldn't even
watch it I don't know so I don't know
how that's going to go um one of the
other ones was improved working
conditions uh sag after uh is also
seeking to improve working conditions
for its members including limitations on
technical requirements and slate
requirements as well as transparency in
the audition process yeah sometimes the
auditions are weird man especially these
like at home auditions you know it's
like it's weird you know it's a weird
it's a weird process um so you know
hopefully they they get all this figured
out
but I just know one of the things they
were asking for you know like it's like
in the writer strike what they got was
because um there's like this thing where
you know projects over $30 million
projects if they hit
certain you know benchmarks they're
going to get extra residuals you know
Netflix is just going to be like well
here's $29 million to make your project
you know what I mean that's how they G
to do that and then the other one was
you know you had to get 20% of the
entire subscription base to watch your
show in the first 90
days I think they agree to that because
no show does that that's what I think
they're G to find out I think it's going
to be like you know if the if the
domestic viewership is 200 million or
however many people you know 20% of
that is what in the first 90 days what
what what's the math on that
that's for if it's if it's 200 million
subscribers that would be 40 million
people accounts have to watch your show
or movie in the first 90 days 40
million if it's 200 million subscribers
and I believe that's what it is I don't
even know I have to look up to whatever
that is but it's go it's a real big
number and I think they agree to that
because they're like they know they have
the numbers they looking at their things
like yeah 4 shows hit that and no shows
already getting paid you know what I
mean like let's say you make a little
sitcom you know like that one there was
this one Jamie Fox sitcom that ain't
getting that ain't getting 10 million
views you know what I'm saying in the
first 90 days I think that we're going
to strike again in three
years watch in three years they gonna be
striking again because they're going to
realize this's gonna be they're GNA be
like oh no shows hit these benchmarks
and then Netflix is going to be like
yeah I know and we're fronting the bill
to to make your show so we made your
show nobody watches it and you want more
money it's going to be tough tough
negotiations but I hope it works
out last up guys I don't know if you
guys ever watch this show billions on
Showtime oh man I love the first few
seasons you know it's about like a
billionaire you know greedy person
trying to you know just get a lot of
money and kind of skirting the law and
then you know uh what's his name um Paul
Giamatti he was playing like the the law
he's like he's the district attorney
he's a US attorney you know throughout
the show throughout the seasons he's
been had different positions in in in
the government and he was like the main
adversary of this like whoever the the
billionaire was and for a long time it
was Damon Damen Lewis who was a
fantastic British actor man he's so good
and so but then like just you know
Season 4 or whatever it was he left the
show and then they then the show was
taken over by this other guy I believe
his name is um I forgot the guy's name
he's on wait wait actually let me go to
the star let me go to the stars of the
show on uh on uh imdb oh I wish they
would show the cast or let's see oh
they're not showing let me see series oh
directed by oh here we go here's the
cast uh what's this guy's name because
he's
great
um is that him
oh no no he's good he that guy's good
yeah the guy yeah uh you know Paul Gatti
Maggie Sif she played Wendy Rose she was
good David conable that guy was good DOA
Rashad she's great um let's see where
where's uh yeah there was Damen Lewis
Dan soder's on it he's been on it for
years he was great where's this why are
they showing this guy here he goes Corey
sto I I didn't know that guy's name
crazy Corey stole he um you know so he
took over as like the main bad guy in
like the last two seasons uh so you know
it's it's like if
you it's I would watch the show you know
it's it was you know it's kind of like
succession before succession just like
you know a rich guy trying to make a
bunch of money and and like you know
cutting corners and uh you know the the
different relationships uh you know that
he had and it was like you know smart
people doing smart stuff but anyway
in the final season the last six or
seven episodes they kind of like made
the guy that that play Cory guy they
kind of made him Trump in a way of like
this sort of Rich billionaire guy that
wants to be president and these guys
were you know the other guys were like
they know what kind of personality his
and they were trying to stop him from
doing that and just the way they went
about it I I thought it was like it was
great storytelling good action
um you know I don't know it was good you
know I mean I just
you know you can catch up on it you know
they have it on so many different ways
to watch Showtime now it's like Amazon
it's like YouTube TV or you get it with
whatever subscription you have and
whatever service that's not paying the
actors enough money just find it
someplace right there and I highly
recommend it
but anyways guys I appreciate you guys
for uh you know always coming every
single week you know I always appreciate
the uh the the the back and forth B ENT
and the the comments I got to get back
to real world advice for a grown ass man
I am going to have a few I'm going to
try to have a few guests on but I got to
go back to the all things comedy studio
for that because you know I'm having a
baby and like my place is like I don't
like I don't want people coming here
anymore unless I really really know them
like RI Glassman or someone like that
but I've been getting a lot of requests
like hey man you know can do so and so
come on your podcast and that kind of
stuff so I I am going to have guests you
know but most of the people that I
uh I don't know you know what I mean I
don't know them and I don't you know
it's it's like Rachel don't like
strangers then then we do have the baby
it's like I don't want hey this is my
baby and let's go into the other the my
office which is my office is also a mess
now because we're moving everything out
of this baby room and you then I have to
like now I have to like look at all my
stuff and go do I really need that I got
to throw that away is that is that
really necessary to have that you know
what I'm saying so
it's just a lot of stuff but again once
again thanks for watching make sure you
subscribe share and I will be at the
Tampa Improv this weekend so if you're
in improv Tampa s Splitters Side
Splitters in Tampa s Splitters in Tampa
two shows Friday two shows Saturday you
go to a griffin.com I got the link for
the tickets right there y'all so make
sure you guys come check that out um oh
wait what's going on with
my can you guys oh here we
go oh yeah
let me start the music over y'all for
the rap
recap
yeah oh rap
woo uh we brought it
back the
NFL it's doing
SW oh
hell billions end
it full send
it
uh say going get what they
want I don't
know even this
flow all
right I'm not in a flow mood today but
thanks for watching riffin with
Griffin I'm tired for my workout I'll
see you guys next week thanks for being
here
peace
sh